I'm so man it did it did here but onward
possibly having the lowest box office
opening for Pixar really that's probably
because the trailers didn't communicate
it so man did it but it did it did boo
it might be because of the coronavirus
actually people are really scared leave
their homes I know it's scary but
personally I'm not afraid of the
worst-case scenario you know why I think
I know your goodness cuz I got soul man
did it dip but it did it bit boo John
this isn't funny this has been a
terrible year horrible start to a decade
I mean it's only March I'm starting to
lose faith you're losing faith yeah just
scared dude if you don't have faith it
sounds like you don't have a soul man
did it bit but it babe it boo I'm sorry
I'm sorry man I'm being really
insensitive today there's no room for
comedy here
yeah there was a time where I was the
insensitive one announcing but you are I
know I know I'm sorry it's just weird
you know you used to have a kind so man
oh did it did it the soul man did it did
the song even in the movie I don't think
so
[Music]
what what is this place
Oh campaign honey I'm Joe I teach middle
school band go for they started out as
the best day of my life
back here tonight first shows itself
[Music]
[Music]
this is where no no touch
[Music]
she ran gossip
all this living really worth the I can
win a lot get them one thousand stalls
going to the great beyond everyday you
know I can't easy single one of them
[Music]
that looks fantastic
yeah that looks incredible that's a
Pixar joy yeah oh my goodness uh I know
onward is underperforming there might be
a variety of reasons maybe people
weren't wrong knew it all the jokes you
made it okay good
the corona virus has been scaring some
people to go out may I don't know what
there's a lot of like random factors
that could be playing into it I hope by
the time this comes out though that a
lot of people flocked to the theaters
because I'm this director who has done
such great films with Pixar already
looking at this trailer he gives you
everything that made Pixar special yes
the animation is absolutely drop-dead
gorgeous elusive ethereal beyond that
and no pun intended and got a lot of
soul and it really does there's a lot of
spirit everything I got her puns today
one pretty enough what they said one of
the things was that originally they had
the main character as a scientist and
they ultimately wound up changing it
because they wanted it to be something
that the audience could more easily get
on board with and that has that element
of soul that easily connects with people
yeah and so that's why they went with
music and you know musical expression as
the thrust for the movie yeah it's got
like double meaning to it the metaphors
they have visually he's like going into
the before as they call it in this
trailer that look like musical notes
actually have a hard time coded with my
thoughts right now because I'm so blown
away by how messing this whole trailer
look this was a real Pixar you know
trailer to me that's got me really
excited because it looks out of the box
in terms of both its storytelling Anna's
animation style and J yeah it's like
funny but very heartfelt I'm drawn to
the main character already it's
interesting to me that like Coco dealt
with the afterlife and this is dealing
with
the before they'll have to be a little
bit sensitive with some subject material
in terms of dealing with phase
questioning is this heaven
he's seen himself on the deathbed I
really don't know how this movie will
end will there be some weird thing where
Tina Fey's character like hops into his
body I'm really unsure of what's gonna
go on because from what I remember I'd
actually didn't do research this morning
remember we researched this when we
first most like to use your truth about
something with a little foggy my brain
Sina face character she's never
experienced life before no she's just
been in this before life for so long
that she has a yeah idea about it okay
so maybe it'll give him that she'll give
her the chance to experience through him
it's like will he come back to life at
the end of it will he be able to keep on
living like I love that existential
question that they posed here is all
this living really worth dying for I
feel like it'll explore the beauties the
joys of life but also the challenges of
life the person who's sort of the
fish-out-of-water for life will be Tina
Fey's character and he'll be like
communicating to her throughout about
like the struggles the the hardships but
also the the things to celebrate the
joys and I feel like have explored in
that gray area here this seems like it
could be a really deep thought-provoking
film but also have that beautiful
animation mixed with some really funny
stuff and I'm excited for the music
they're gonna provide like Coco really
hit the nail on the head what's having
some really memorable music oh
definitely get a different flavor of
music but a probably just as impactful
and integral to the story telling us oh
yeah well speaking of the music too I
mean you'll have a couple of unique
elements because you have Trent Reznor
and Atticus Ross doing the main musical
score and then you have Jon batiste he's
on the Colbert show now but he's also
like the head of the jazz museum in
America and stuff like that like the
curator for that so he's writing a lot
of jazz songs for the movie so yeah I
imagine the soundscape is gonna be
really vibrant and one thing they said
they wanted to do which it looks like
they're getting at here and and I love
about Pixar's when they go after big
questions but in a fun sort of way yeah
because yeah I feel like and again more
soul puns but this movie does look like
it has a tremendous amount of soul in it
in a variety of directions because you
know you've got that fish-out-of-water
element for her
and earth but also for him and the
before and after lives yeah and you have
yeah that chance to get really life II
about it and if you look at back it
films like us or Wally or inside out you
know there are a lot of elements up yes
real left turn there they aren't afraid
to go after the harder more challenging
emotions of life while also keeping
their hand firmly on the charm and the
humor and all that stuff and like I said
at the time this looks like a
quintessential Pixar joint and
especially from Pete docter who's like
the head of Pixar now that's an
inspiring thing to see that if this is
his baby you know that's probably a good
choice to replace Lasseter and with
Jamie Foxx breaking up with Katie Holmes
didn't even know they were really dating
until I found out they were broken up
what he needs this he need not respond
anymore apparently
Katie Holmes will be fine well what do
you think of this us trailer subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification bail check us out on
patreon TV show reactions watched along
then some shows the reaction has
included he does music video reactions
weekly last but not least its end this
with a David Gandy yesterday it was your
birthday dude so we're getting this
video up just a little bit late wanted
to wish you a happy 29th birthday I'm
assuming when David first found us he
actually said that it was when he was
recovering from cancer he was in the
hospital and he would watch our videos
constantly I'm friends with him on
Facebook
that's no long has been a patron so I
gotta do to become my facebook friend
just be a longtime patron object he been
put out on his Facebook page he's
sharing the fundraiser for the John
Wayne Cancer Foundation I'm putting a
link in the description box and a link
in the pin comment I've donated myself
you guys should go ahead and donate to
the John Wayne Cancer Foundation
Cantor's a real problem in this world
the David is someone who is a survivor
from it and he is a creative beautiful
human being I love chatting with this
guy wonderful artist wonderful martial
artist as well apparently and a killer
musician you know because because the
soul trailer so if you guys can go ahead
sure sport asked me to go to our patron
I'm asking you to go help out folks with
cancer happy birthday David thank you so
much for being here
you